Comment transformer une
feuille de papier en table?
Le papier c'est parfait pour écrire
ou pour dessiner, mais comme table ou
support pour un verre ce n'est pas terrible
le papier étant souple et non rigide.
Ayonsconfiance en notre papier et voyons comment
corriger ses petits défauts. Pour cela je vais
avoir besoin de deux grands livres qui vont
servir de support, d'un verre ou d'une tasse
et d'une feuille de papier. Si l' on met la
feuille de papier comme ceci et qu'on pose
le verre dessus, cela ne tient pas, ça tombe.
Mais en pliant la feuille en accordéon, on va
observer quelque chose de différent. C'est
parti on va venir donc plier la feuille en
accordéon comme ceci en faisant des plis pas
trop serré mais assez étroit.
Nous avons maintenant notre feuille pliée en
accordéon que l'on va légèrement déplier, remettre
nos livres et la poser comme ceci. Et quand on
repose le verre dessus on observe que cela tient.
Qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé? En pliant la feuille
en accordéon tu augmentes sa rigidité, elle est
plus difficile à plier sur la largeur, plus les
plis sont épais et rapprochés, plus la feuille sera
rigide. Assez pour supporter le poids d' un verre.
Ces plis sont appelés des cannelures, à l'inverse
si les cannelures ne sont pas assez rapprochées la
feuille n'est plus assez rigide pour supporter
le verre. Si tu observes l'épaisseur d'un carton
tu verras que celui ci est ondulé. La rigidité du
carton est due à la présence des cannelures. Il
y a plusieurs dispositions possibles : une seule
couche de cannelures, double couches, triple couches
une seule couverture ou doubles etc . Plus il y a
de cannelures ou de couvertures plus le carton sera
résistant et capable de supporter de lourdes
charges. Merci d'avoir regarder cet épisode. Je
t'invite à refaire cette expérience chez toi,
et te donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour répondre à une nouvelle question.